I've been telling my followers and I
think this is just important for people
to do is if what you're viewing on
social media is making you feel worse
then you have to stop looking at it
right social media also caters to what
you click on so if you're like okay this
was kind of interesting and it's this
clickbaity video that makes your outlook
of the world more negative it's just
going to keep showing you those things
because you press on them so you have to
think about how you want your life to be
right and probably surrounding yourself
with resentful people whether or not
you're in the like red pill Community or
on the like way over on the left if it's
making you resentful especially towards
the opposite sex too whom you're going
to have to have a relationship with if
you want to have a family maybe you
shouldn't be watching content that makes
you resentful and then potentially stops
you from having a relationship and a
family like maybe watch something more
positive